all right thanks some well that was my
thoughts came back I don't know how that
happened it's been a while
didn't stream that one amazing hey let's
do it where we drop in sorry I rudely
didn't even offer you guys you wanted to
play I was but I am a lifeline mate it's
kind of my thing that that I knew you
excellent you know well how's that
related I appreciate it
let me scan you're scared I think
excuse me sir
you see excuse me sir hiccup I was just
trying to do that come on I'm serious
how's the circle looking hmm we're a
little closer to the center than I mean
like we are in an open imme yeah we're
probably gonna it's probably gonna be a
squad well who did that though oh never
mind
oh you are you got lit what if I just
finish your friend writing it's fine if
you want to do it right now cuz we got
other things to deal with
I'm ready here's the do the Gibraltar he
goes right here oh the other guy I'm not
sure kill him they both had purple this
week in the decade way use some better
Bonnie almonds anyone got purple no big
Tings and dad's okay that's probably
gonna draw people to us meet you guys
nice you sound just like the voice yeah
thank you I've considered voice acting
myself alright bubble shield
alright what do you guys we'll take that
helmet helmet who wants to help me I
don't you can take it go for it you look
yeah you look very nice I like your skin
a lot there oh well you probably should
have taken that but why didn't you tell
us that when we were like who wants to
helmet did we see anyone in here Rose
over there okay over there on the roof
no they're probably trying they're gonna
hit the train probably trying to gonna
hit the tree I'm very scared I'm going
down feeling I should I need to get me
you guys I'm you goddamn lifeline well
of the team I'm coming work
Oh God I know I just I don't feel good
about how we've handled this I don't
feel good about it I'm worried I mean
son very nervous was so open there are
two squad he should be super close to
yeah I'm also down
both teams have Papa Lohmann I'm coming
I'm coming to ya oh yeah on me pretty
much did you just say please white well
I hope this works
yeah grenade it's okay it's okay don't
don't get me if you're not safe you guys
might be fine to do this without me it's
not what the risk nice work hell yeah
all right
I felt very terrified about that
happening um all right where you guys
from I'm in Maryland police okay I'm in
Texas West Texas alright it's a cargo
boat we can shoot at sure okay I don't
see a problem with doing that I Stiles
know that's going on yeah she didn't
shoot whatever you want I'm over here
but you know that doesn't mean anything
to me right I'm over here yes
I assume you are somewhere
all right we got one that's it squat
yeah hang on let me come over here with
a turn for you
how about five squads left well they all
just hanging out is this some kind of
orgy like what are you doing it's very
good book wild oh sure what was that I
just don't know what you're talking
about I'm trying to make my webcam
slightly smaller oh he's right okay
let's get in here let's get in here make
him come to us broke his armor cool then
maybe we should just go for it yeah a
few burgers Alma we can go the race yeah
right on top okay thank you for the pain
right here I only saw two no that's a
papaya it's not my finest work nothing
like waiting 20 minutes for that to
happen thank you for that Epson shot
everyone I really appreciate that
good shot it is right there
Oh runnin damn mama
damn whoa all right we got people to our
left I just got a fan picked up I'm not
good with a wing man I wish I was you
know I don't want any of this okay
well hey at least we jumped into action
this time right no calm down that's not
great I killed one bad for this at all
but you know get back here you yay
oh wow the whole squad is here don't
bother with me
nevermind alright I got one uh where are
you oh I can deliver you to the beacon
so I'm just gonna do that right now oh
we got people any on top of me right
here first a pass
yeah yeah that's a grenade well yeah get
in here
I'll set us up I'll get us some gas and
everything is it a whole squad I saw two
people flying their jet pack in maybe
three has somebody's on the roof and
they just okay so they're in the
building or almost in the building I'm
worried about that door a little bit
right outside yeah there oh they're
trying to push in from where whoa whoa I
just I hate that I don't know where they
are it's like we're sitting ducks when
this kind of thing happens all right we
got one on my side
I'm definitely being shut up from behind
whoa they got all of us just then
there's whoa
that was so quick I also died ropeway I
got one shotted damn you guys want to
when I'm ready up jump in and hit that Y
button I was really sad when Bruce left
naturally I was really sad when Bruce
left the day that he pulled me into a
room and told me I was he was like I
think I think it was like I have
something to tell you and I was like
you're leaving and he was like yeah and
I like clutched my chest and was like it
was like genuinely very upsetting oh oh
I was gonna go to the train but it's
near the hot zone yeah that's true right
now so I thought it would be too much
absolutely and when I can tell right now
it looks like we're dropping by
ourselves so Bruce Lee do you know much
about this game or is this all confusing
to you like do you know do you know much
about apex at all I like first apply and
learn there we go yeah true you did do
the training but I'm like you know what
we're talking about if we talk about
dropping and stuff oh damn it nice supe
dude thank you
well the best weapon is like a little
bit subjective not like entirely but um
that's kind of a thing that you figure
out while you play oh yeah yeah I killed
a man
I was killed somewhere where you tell me
to come back for man's dead we good we
good there's only one though I don't I
don't know where anyone else is I
appreciate that means a lot
did you have a shotgun II [ __ ] didn't
come on all right
I'll kill a [ __ ]
couple that's mine open it open it where
did it go where did he go okay yeah well
the lifeline still he has some way about
where are you a lifeline a little punk
later dude is that huh we just like
gloated about my finish uh no no it's
it's the same team that's it oh no what
happened grizzly that's right we got you
oh there's another team [ __ ] okay okay
okay okay I don't really need it but why
not you know
I'll stay in there but I think we should
run in so don't let the ring kill us oh
you're fine no thank you fine we are
aggressively talkative I'm sorry we are
talking too much
oh I broke a shield but that's it
I think if we both go for it we're good
let's go it's just a wraith right okay
my [ __ ] you go [ __ ] where you go show
yourself woman no I lost her maybe she
just like well this this fighting I mean
that could be her yeah I'm a wrench just
do some drugs man and we'll see if we
can get you back grizzly oh there's only
flex what's left we do need we do need
to get him back
well we're gonna we're gonna do our best
if you just stay on me right now I feel
like our defense is a better we're
coordinated we're gonna I'm gonna get
West Virginia back in the [ __ ] game
Wow
okay that could come in handy okay
grizzly here's what you're gonna do what
are you gonna [ __ ] this is deep well at
least get that get that right there it's
fine it's fine it's fine you're not
having any just what I'm gonna say is
just follow me as quickly as you can
that's it that's what you're gonna
[ __ ] do you know get your ass right
over here we're gonna give you this you
know what I'm going to give you my flat
line can I just drop the whole [ __ ]
drop pick it pick that up oh can we is
there uh help here follow me follow me
follow me no I can't I don't think we
can safely get that dude [ __ ] I didn't
bread it and see that sorry grizzly oh
yeah yeah I know I know I know I know I
don't stop the other man is being
attacked we got it okay
nice work on that grizzly you got that
on the jump okay it's uh that's not
gonna go well for me did not go well did
not go well we got you back though I'm
happy about it and they're on they're on
both sides I think it might be done I
think we might have [ __ ] it okay you
did Oh
are you dead are you dead [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
we tried that was good yeah I'm sorry I
didn't a Q a de quickly support you at
the end that grizzly that is my bad that
was in pot my fault I'm sorry that's a
long view the great thank you